se nos dice que las primeras cinco
energías de ionización para un elemento
del tercer periodo se muestran a
continuación cuál es la identidad del
elemento pausa en este vídeo y ver si
pueden resolverlo ustedes mismos y
probablemente sea útil tener una tabla
periódica de los elementos incluso antes
de mirar la tabla periódica de los
elementos asegurémonos de entender lo
que esta tabla nos dice esto nos dice
que si comenzamos con un átomo neutro de
este elemento misterioso se necesitarían
578 kilos por mol para eliminar ese
primer electrón para convertir ese átomo
en unión con una carga positiva más uno
y luego tomaría otros mil 817 kilos por
mol para eliminar el segundo electrón
para hacer ese ion aún más positivo
luego de eso se necesitarían otros dos
mil 745 kilos por mol para eliminar el
tercer electrón después para eliminar el
cuarto electrón se requiere una cantidad
mucho mayor de energía se necesitarían
11 mil 578 kilos por mol
el quinto electrón toma aún más 14 mil
842 kilos por mol así que para el
primero el segundo y el tercero tenemos
un aumento en la energía de ionización
pero cuando pasamos al cuarto la energía
requerida para quitar los electrones es
mucho mayor entonces a mí me parece que
en estos estamos eliminando electrones
de valencia y en estos otros parece que
estamos eliminando electrones centrales
entonces una forma de pensar en esto es
buscar en nuestra tabla periódica de los
elementos un elemento del tercer periodo
que tenga tres electrones de valencia
tenemos la tabla periódica de los
elementos queremos un elemento del
tercer periodo por lo que estará en esta
tercera fila y cuál de éstos tiene tres
electrones de valencia
bueno el sodio tiene un electrón de
valencia el magnesio tiene dos
electrones de valencia el aluminio tiene
tres electrones de valencia una forma de
pensar en esto es que ese primer
electrón tiene una energía de ionización
razonable luego el segundo un poco más
alto
el tercero un poco más alto en el cuarto
estamos acercándonos al centro tenemos
que sacar un electrón de esa segunda
capa de energía completa lo que requiere
mucha energía y así lo que se está
describiendo claramente es aluminio